se habla mucho del autoexamen del
constante monitoreo pero qué
procedimientos o qué hábitos se pueden
adquirir para prevenir esta enfermedad
buenas noches andrew buenas noches a
todos los televidentes pues mira no se
sabe la causa del cáncer del seno de eso
tenemos que decirlo en primer lugar al
no conocer su causa la prevención del
cáncer del seno es imposible lo que sí
podemos hacer y eso es parte de tu
pregunta es hacer que las mujeres
detecten temprano al cáncer que ya
empezó y para eso conocer su pecho
haciéndose el examen una vez al mes
yendo al médico para que el doctor la
doctora le haga un examen anual de sus
pechos desde los 18 20 años de edad y
haciéndose una radiografía de las de los
senos la mamografía empezando a los 40
años son los tres métodos para encontrar
temprano el cáncer cuáles son estas
señales de alarma que indican que puede
haber cáncer de seno
ninguna absolutamente ninguna el cáncer
no te da ninguna señal no da dolor no da
nada por eso es que la detección precoz
es importante por ejemplo la figura que
estamos viendo a esa señora le están
haciendo una mamografía ella no siente
nada no tiene dolor no tiene nada pero
en esa mamografía andrés allí van a
salir unos puntitos que estamos viendo
allí que son del tamaño de un granito de
azúcar ya son cáncer no da ninguna señal
la clave es la detección precoz doctor y
que podemos decirle esas mujeres que dan
por sentado el autoexamen entonces
las que dan por sentado por sentado
exámenes discúlpeme claro las otras que
dan por sentado el autoexamen que de
pronto no creen que esto puede ayudar a
detectar a tiempo el cáncer de mama ya
es
bueno ya que hay que ayudarlas a que hay
que tratar de que los médicos privados
las lajas las ayuden y para eso es
importante empezar desde la niñez a
andrés las niñas las las chicas en las
escuelas secundarias en las
universidades deben ser enseñadas de la
doctora estaba examinando el pecho la
mujer también lo puede hacer es cuestión
de empezar desde el temprano desde la
niñez desde la juventud para que
adquieran el hábito de hacerse sus
exámenes